the disney company in the early 90s
20 years earlier we're giving benefits
to
partners of their gay employees so once
again we've got the free market
looking out for the individuals because
they have to
to make a profit they want to hire the
best employees so they've got to
basically put into you know uh you know
about a peer pressure
so we focused obviously more on on trump
because he's the president and policies
of the conservatives
what do you make about what's going on
with the democrats right now and what
seems to be a war
between the younger progressive lefties
versus a little bit
i guess of what's left of the old guard
there ain't much left and i think it's
sort of summed up by
it's summed up by biden what do you make
about what's going on there
well but the old guard is still strong
and the thing that i've been pointing
out is how they muzzled tulsi gabbard
how they
unfairly kept her out of the debates and
what's such a shame
is that the democratic party used to be
the party of peace
they used to be the anti-war party and
they've got a great anti-war candidate
uh tulsi gabbard by the way let me
qualify that and say
great on that position i mean i realize
yes she's socialist on the economic
issues and that's why i wouldn't vote
for her that's why i'm running for
president
excuse me but on the war issues she's
great
and yet the government is the the
democratic establishment kept her
out of the debates because i wanted to
quiet her down so
yeah the old guard there may not be many
of them left but they sure are powerful
and that's really a shame and that
brings me by the way just one other
quick point is
uh you know i talk about how the the
democratic party used to be the anti-war
party
when i first joined the movement and
people asked me what a libertarian was
what i would say is well we take the
best of both sides you know
we take the best parts about the right
about the republicans so we believe in
economic freedoms
and we take the best about the left that
we're anti-war
that we believe in individual liberty
and
now i can't say that anymore because
democrats aren't acting like democrats
and republicans aren't acting like
republicans and maybe it was coincidence
that they even agreed with us
and young people are shocked when i tell
them that as recently as 2012
barack obama and hillary clinton both
were against gay marriage
meanwhile the libertarian party was for
individual rights you know they were
advocating gay marriage in 1972 i hate
to say advocating advocating the rights
you know not that everybody should do it
but advocating
whereas democrats that's a whole
different that sounds far
more authoritarian yeah
yeah the the people at the top you know
of the democratic party they're saying
gay marriage should be illegal and if
you don't mind
let me bring in one other free market
item here
the disney company in the early 90s
20 years earlier were giving benefits
to partners of their gay employees so
once again
we've got the free market looking out
for the individuals
because they have to to make a profit
they want to hire the best employees so
they've got to
basically put into you know uh you know
about a peer pressure
so and you know going back to racists
and and all those laws again
the free market can do such a much
better job than the government at
anything
what do you make about uh what's going
on with biden do you think something's
wrong there
well i'm not a clinical psychologist but
even if i were i think there's some law
that would keep me from diagnosing him
but my answer is
it doesn't what concerns me is what he
was saying 10
20 years ago i mean what he was saying
10 20 years ago
as a younger man that made absolutely no
sense what worries me is
you know how he thought the crime bill
was such a good thing to pass in the 90s
so people are saying well maybe he's not
all with it now i
i would suggest he wasn't with it 20 or
30 years ago
all right i got one more for you i'm
gonna i'm gonna toss you a softball here
and just tell you that
as i as i think you know i have a lot of
disaffected
liberals that watch this show i have a
lot of what i would call
sort of new school conservatives and and
even old school conservatives
but i would say generally at this point
my audience leans probably center right
joe jorgensen make your make your pitch
for why they should vote for you
uh on november 4th i would say i
understand why you voted for trump to
the conservatives in 2016.
he came in as an outsider he said he was
going to cut the budget he was going to
cut spending
he said he was a businessman who knew
how to get things done and he would
bring the troops home but he didn't do
any of that and i would say to the
democrats
you know again the democratic party has
traditionally been the party of peace
uh they shut down tulsi gabbard they
shut down bernie sanders
basically you've got a very slick party
machine
going on that gave you joe biden even
though you don't want him
if you really want an outsider then
please check me out and go to joe20.com
that's jo20.com
and i think you'll see that we are
really
uh what you believe in we are the ones
giving you what you want and i'm so
excited to announce that
something like 75 of our volunteers are
from
outside the party because they realize
that they're just not
that that the two old parties just
aren't giving them what they want
all right i thank you for your time i'm
glad we were finally able to do this
and uh good luck the rest of the way
what can i ask you one quick question
sure so you voted for gary johnson have
i won your vote
that's good that's good joe listen i am
so
frustrated by what is happening with the
left and
the destruction of our institutions
academic
media institutions everything else and i
at this point i see trump as the bulwark
against that the ideas that you've laid
out here for the little marginal
differences we have
i think are are the right ideas my
audience knows that i i say that all the
time i don't think
this time that i can vote for a third
party to to be totally honest and i get
you hear a lot of that
and i think you can probably hear it in
my voice that it's not
the way i sort of want to go in a
certain regard but i think trump has
done enough
on the big things that i care about um
but i'll be happy to discuss this with
you privately maybe the day before the
election how about that
gonna make one last plea to your uh
viewers
yeah which is many of you live in a
solidly red
state like i do uh you know we were one
of only six states to carry bob dole
your state's going to carry donald trump
anyway the red states are going to give
donald trump the electoral college votes
if you want to send a message to trump
that you don't like that he's gotten you
bigger government
vote for me because trump's going to get
the electoral votes anyway
if you live in a solidly blue state like
california joe biden's going to get it
if you're not happy with what your
candidate is doing
then vote for me because in the solid
red and solid blue states it's not going
to make much of a difference so let's
send some
kind of message you know what joe that
that is
totally in line with what i was saying
four years ago and that's why i was
fighting for
gary johnson to get into the debates
because my thought was okay
if the if the libertarian isn't going to
win let's just
you know if that's just not realistic at
the moment i'm talking four years ago
then at least let's get these ideas out
there it starts with ideas
and if that's a policy or if that's an
idea that can get you to seed some of
these good ideas out there
uh ideologically i'm totally with you
okay
well thanks so much i hope to be on your
show again hint
yeah i enjoyed it and good luck and
we'll talk again
thanks thanks thanks so much had a great
time if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell